hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter three
of Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics there
occurs a very important discussion quite
quit laughing actually on Aristotle's
part dealing with the relationship
between pleasure and pain on the one
hand these affective states and virtue
and vice on the other hand really what
it comes down to is an extended argument
about why pleasure and pain are
important for the person who is
concerned with virtue or vice to take
into account you notice we've got eighty
different points up here on the board
because Aristotle actually goes through
eight you know separate reasons but the
real upshot of this is what we put here
first pleasure and pain as Aristotle
says provide a kind of index or sign
more literally samay on all of the
dispositions that a person has so if you
want to know whether they really are
virtuous or vicious you have to look not
just at what they're doing but how
they're feeling about it and so likewise
if we're going to think about our own
case whether we're virtuous or vicious
or somewhere in between we want to look
at where pleasure and pain arise for us
so Aristotle will say for example in
that section the temper
person is not simply one who does temper
actions but somebody who feels pleasure
in doing or even in considering
tempering actions and who feels a sense
of pain or disease the loop aid could
mean not just you know physical pain
like you know poking yourself well I'm
gonna kind of in English or you know
being troubled some of you know the the
the temperate person in seeing other
people and intemperately is effectively
bothered by it but when they see other
people acting temperately they enjoy it
when they do it themselves they enjoy it
and this is a very important index like
we said because if you don't actually
enjoy doing the right thing that means
that you're not quite virtuous yet so
all that said let's take a look at these
these really fascinating arguments that
are being or points around them that are
being advanced the first one he says is
pleasure and pain our motives for action
and specifically I didn't put this all
on the board he says pleasure causes us
to do base or ignoble the opposite of
the the column the beautiful it causes
us to do actions that we regret later on
that we think are there's something
beneath us involved in that and we could
think of all sorts of pleasures and
pleasures of taste the pleasures of
sexual desire the pleasures of drink
ordered you know intoxicants other
pleasures you know pleasure can lead us
to doing things that we recognize as not
being the right thing
likewise pain can keep us from doing the
right thing pain can keep us from as
there are some such noble actions and so
we want to pay very close attention to
it so that's the actions the virtues are
concerned the actions they're also
concerned with emotions and that is 0.2
pain and pleasure are connected with
emotions how so it's not just that they
you know they're all effective states as
opposed to say cognition or something
like that
many of the emotions are involving
pleasure in pain sometimes in
complicated ways for example anger one
of the most complex of the emotions in
the aristotelian understanding anger
involves a pain at being slighted by
somebody but it also involves a kind of
pleasure in aiming and thinking about
the retribution that one is going to
impose upon them so it's mingle together
pleasure in there's many other emotions
that involve pleasure or pain as well
Third Point painting is as Aristotle
says the medium of punishment there he's
using a different term than retribution
retribution is two more ASIS
this is kelapa Colossus the sort of
thing that you impose trying to wean
somebody away from behavior that that
you don't want them to be doing that's
bad for that mad for other people and so
pain plays into pleasure it plays into
virtue advice in that if you're trying
to dissuade something from vice you
might actually make it painful for them
to engage in it another point that he's
got here that kind of ties in with the
first play says that people are
corrupted through pleasures and things
that is they're made worse in respect of
their their moral status as men are
corrupted through pleasures and pains
either by pursuing and avoiding the
wrong pleasures of pains or pursuing and
avoiding them at the wrong time or the
wrong manner or in one of the other
wrong ways under which ears of conduct
can be logically classified what we see
here is the discussion of the many
rights and wrongs that go into the
virtuous mean so it's not just a matter
of what we do or the emotions we feel
it's also the pleasures and pains that
we
- or avoid you know at the right time at
the wrong time in the right way at the
in the wrong way and so on those can
have a very important effect on whether
we cultivate virtue or or bias and we
can use how a person is behaving like
it's said and as a sign or an index of
whether they are on the track to virtue
or on the downward slide towards vice
here in the fifth point he talks about a
number of ranges of value and you know
some of these are not directly relevant
to this for instance the you know the
useful and the harmful there would be a
lot of discussion of that elsewhere even
the noble and the the ignoble or the
face here is primarily interested in the
fact that there is the pleasurable and
the painful and people get mixed up
about this and disagree about them
Aristotle thinks that the person who
actually is virtuous that the person who
has cultivated nobility has the best
understanding of what truly is
pleasurable and what truly is painful
well that means is that we're a bit
mixed up about this and we're liable
until we cultivate virtue to go astray
with respect to evaluating pleasures and
pains it's got another interesting
argument in the 6th point we are prone
from birth to follow pleasure it's a
very natural thing for us Freud actually
calls this the pleasure principle right
that then beatings desire the pleasure
he's not coming up with that by the way
you have materials knew that you know
Plato and Aristotle already knew that so
it's something that we need to be on
guard against and he doesn't say oh we
need to be on guard against it so
therefore pleasure is bad as a matter of
fact pleasures a good thing it's you
know in the range of moral qualities is
a good thing but we do need to be more
careful precisely because it is such
part of our nature the seven point he
says that pleasure and pain are
standards by which we order our actions
the term that he actually uses there in
the Greek is kind of kind of neat kind
of needs of men that's the the first
person plural of it saying that we
regulate or we strictly speaking apply a
manager a cannon a rule so if we're not
careful about how we're applying this
standard we can get ourselves in lots of
trouble if we adopt a very strict
hedonism and say that pleasure is really
the only good that's going to make it
very difficult for us to cultivate
virtue in the way that Aristotle
understands it
likewise if we're always just trying to
avoid pain also going to be very
difficult think about the way courage
would play out right it's not fun to be
afraid and so our tendency might be to
turn away from anything that makes us
nervous or anxious and as we do that we
become cowards and you know we lose the
pleasure of the process but perhaps
avoid some pains the eighth and final
point is a very interesting thing that
he says and he actually quotes the
actually quotes Heraclitus here so it's
harder to play it against pleasure than
anger and we know how hard it is to
fight against anger because hair Clint's
told us about that but virtue is
concerned with the difficult virtue
cultivates what is best in human beings
by raising them out of the mediocre to
something higher so if it is harder to
fight against pleasure than anger and
anger is very tough to control isn't it
and tough to say no to then virtue is
going to be eminently concerned with
pleasure so all of these are reasons why
pleasure and pain matter to virtue but
keep in mind that all of them feed into
this notion that what a person feels
pleasure in or painting
is a sign of their inner dispositions
whether they are virtuous vicious or
somewhere in between